President Trump won the night with a far
better than average State of the Union
address that boldly declared America
will never be a socialist country poor
Bernie Sanders sulking in the corner of
course the mainstream media couldn't
tolerate that
so they unleashed a torrent of dishonest
fact checks we will fact check the fact
checkers then a better-than-average
Democrat response as well we will
discuss why but ultimately it still fell
flat
huzzah hooray the Republic fights
another day I'm Michael Nolan this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
a good night a good night for President
Trump a good night for the Republican
Party and a very good night for America
we covered the State of the Union last
night here for about it felt like about
18 or 27 hours so we won't go through
point by point on the State of the Union
what I want to focus on is the reaction
to the State of the Union that's in the
mainstream media that's among the
Democrat Party that I think is probably
more interesting than the speech itself
but first we have got to make a little
money honey we can do it with 1-800
flowers by now most of us are racking
our brains what to give our little
honeys for Valentine's Day with 1-800
flowers calm it's not that complicated
roses from 1-800 flowers are a
no-brainer right now when you order
early 1-800 flowers has amazing deals on
vibrant and romantic rose bouquets
arrangements and more just starting at
$29.99
I gave one of these to sweet little
Alisa last night and she loved it said
listen I know I've been covering the
State of the Union for two years now you
know you haven't seen me in months and
but anyway here are these flowers she
loved them they're really really nice
and they come beautifully packaged so
the flowers don't get damaged do they
look really nice the bouquet prices will
be going up soon so take advantage today
pick your delivery date look 100 flowers
handle the rest when it comes to
Valentine's I do not settle for anything
less than my rose Authority 1-800
flowers calm to order Valentine's
bouquets arrangements and more at 29
starting at $29.99 go to 1-800 flowers
com click the radio icon and enter code
qoph FAC o VF e f e order today and save
it 1-800 flowers calm promo code cough
FAC OV e fe fe before we get to the
reaction let's just start with one of
the best lines of the entire night maybe
the most important line of the night
which has prompted probably the most
vocal reaction we are alarmed by the new
calls to adopt socialism in our country
[Music]
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not that coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay free
[Applause]
so if you didn't see here Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders looking so upset so
frustrated we renew our resolve that
America will never be a socialist
country
on red buoys things down even further in
his chair he's so very upset now you'll
notice here one of the more interesting
things about the state of the union is
you look at who's clapping who's not
clapping who's standing who won't stand
Burnie sinking down into his chair even
Nancy Pelosi clapped at that line
America will never be a socialist
country she didn't stand in clap but she
did clap now obviously Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez Bernie Sanders those Bolsheviks
currently in our government they would
not clap over Stan but Nancy did and
this is important this is a good sign
the line is very important because I
actually do fear encroaching socialism
in America I do fear it you now have the
majority of Millennials identify as
socialists you now it's just creeping
along as it often does and a little
confidence goes a long way
the Democrats always do this they make
bold declarations often crazy sounding
declarations and then they say them
often enough and then they get repeated
by the mainstream media and then they
start to sink in and this is how they
took over the culture Republicans should
be able to do that too we should we
should make these bold declarations
now what if America one day becomes a
socialist country well it won't it won't
happen on my watch
I'm gonna do everything I can to make
sure it doesn't happen on my watch
there's something very Churchillian
about this strategy this is what Winston
Churchill did during the Second World
War during the darkest hours of that war
he said this future generations will
look on us and say this was their finest
hour
we shall go on we should fight in the
beaches and endless streets we shall
never surrender we'll never surrender
and he it was just this total defiance
and it was that sort of defiance the
president from made last night Oh some
socialists won elections oh the
Democratic Party is veering toward
socialism non-socialist Democrats can't
run in the 2020 Democrat primary who
cares America will never be a socialist
country and he linked this to Venezuela
this is very important as well you know
one thing he did is that he came out and
declared the winner of the Venezuelan
election that happened we
- ago he declared that one Guido is the
legitimate president of Venezuela over
the socialist Nicolas Maduro I do love
that the US can do that I do love that
during our State of the Union we can
just declare presidents of other
countries no I'm not being facetious
either we should that country has fallen
to nothing Nicolas Maduro is a
ridiculous dictator who's destroyed that
country after the destruction of Hugo
Chavez great we should kick him out
we should feel nothing wrong about that
it's I assume he won the election
legitimately even if he didn't I'm sorry
I assumed that Guido won the election
legitimately
but even if he didn't I love that the US
can go in there and say we're gonna stop
that misery no more misery uh-uh
get out Maduro too bad try again next
time that's really nice and the
connection to Venezuela is very
important Venezuela had one of the best
economies in the world in in 1950
sometime during the 50s it was the
fourth strongest economy in the world
there it's an oil-rich nation it was a
very wealthy nation and then it was even
in recent memory was doing very well
until socialism crept in and destroyed
it within our lifetimes we've seen
socialism wreck that country and what
President Trump is saying is that people
like Alexandria Cassio Cortes like all
of the incoming socialists like Bernie
Sanders what they want to do is follow
in the footsteps of Venezuela now what
they say is no no no we don't want that
we want to follow the Nordic countries
like Denmark Denmark explicitly says we
are not a socialist country actually all
of those Scandinavian Nordic countries
they did experiment with socialism and
it damaged their economy and they have
since undone a lot of those socialist
reforms they've reinstituted a lot of
capitalist reforms and their economies
have boomed as a result of that so it's
it's totally disingenuous a lot of those
countries have freer economies than the
United States
it's totally disingenuous when
Alexandria Castillo Cortes or whoever
says no no we're just gonna be like
those nice white countries up north
because there's an there is an
underlying racial message here which is
oh no no no
not like those scary countries where
with mixed ethnic populations no just
those places that are 100% ethnically
homogeneous no like that that's the good
socialism it's not even socialism and
and it's and it's increasingly less like
socialism what they're proposing is
Venezuela
even this medicare-for-all plan this
goes so far beyond what you see in the
Nordic countries are what you see in the
United Kingdom where at least there
still exists private health insurance
very often
whereas here Camilla Harris probably the
leading Democrat presidential candidate
is saying we need to abolish private
insurance abolish a totally government
runs everything other Democrats coming
and backing her up on that that the
future that these people see looks like
Venezuela and president Trump pointed
that out of thing was a big win the
other reason America will never be a
socialist country is because of the
incompetent socialist politicians you
know Bernie Sanders never held a job in
his entire life until he got himself
elected and went on the public dole he
had his honeymoon in the Soviet Union
sang shirtless with Soviets talk about
colluding with the Russians but even
better than him we learned last night
that in 1986 Elizabeth Warren claimed
Native American ancestry when she was
filing with the Texas bar now why is
this important this is important because
she has previously said oh I didn't
really do that no I didn't really claim
ancestry it was a mistake by Harvard it
was a bureaucratic error I never used it
to my professional advantage no it's
just a silly misunderstanding
now we have her signature right on the
paper
she claimed in her own handwriting
American Indian ancestry not Harvard not
an administrator but her the the even
will look we all know that she's done
this very few conservatives ever
believed her ridiculous line about not
knowing or not not being aware and never
using it to her advantage
but last week it has since been reported
Elizabeth Warren privately apologized to
Cherokee Chief Bill John Baker privately
not publicly now it later became public
when this was reported but she was sorry
she apologized for quote for furthering
confusion about tribal citizenship and
quote for not being more mindful about
this decades ago so question is why did
Elizabeth Warren apologize last week
what has changed why I mean she
initially she launched her presidential
campaign pretending still to be Native
American because she's won 1024 Native
American maybe so what has changed well
we figured it out last night the
Washington Post reported that Liz Warren
had filed with the Texas State Bar in
1986 as an American Indian so that comes
out last night and yet a week ago she
apologizes privately why would that
happen it seems to me that the
Washington Post tipped her off what else
could it be
when she she then apologized and this
was reported by The Washington Post when
this story came out and what did she
apologize for quote for furthering
confusion about tribal citizenship quote
and for not being more mindful about
this - she is the same language that she
used on a private conversation with
Baker last week so the corruption of all
of this gets even more fetid it gets
even more dank which is that the
Washington Post finds this at they've
been they've been helping to cover from
Liz Warren for a long time they find out
that she actually did commit this fraud
obviously intentionally she did it for a
very long time she did it to further her
career so what do they do they tip off
Liz Warren almost certainly so then she
can get ahead of the story apologize to
the Cherokee Nation then a few days
later The Washington Post reports it
really corrupted The Washington Post is
so transparent about all this and this
is the other reason why America will not
become a socialist country is because
the media cheering it on are so
transparent they look President Trump
gave a very good speech last night he
gave probably a b-plus speech which for
a State of the Union address is very
very good the State of the Union
addresses are awful they're so boring
they're so a largely pointless although
they can't have some shining moments and
he did a very good job so the media are
furious because the Democrat Stacey
Abrams will get to her in a minute she
also did a pretty good job but it just
fell flat by by virtue
of the the reaction always falls flat
and she wasn't that great Trump did a
much better job so the media were
furious and they instantly started
issuing fact checks but the fact checks
are not fact checks they are opinion
columns that's their leftist opinion
columns that dishonestly call themselves
fact checks we'll get to all of those in
a second but first let's make a little
money honey with indulgences valentine's
Day is approaching now I think it makes
perfect sense obviously as the Catholic
at the Daily wire I should sell
indulgences it's a very good product
what are you gonna do for Valentine's
Day it's an age-old dilemma if you go to
your local flower shop you know the day
of you're gonna spend a zillion dollars
and maybe who knows if you can control
the quality sometimes that you know the
flowers don't even last that long if for
chocolates you know you don't want to
get fat you don't you don't you can you
say oh you too so I can't eat those then
you throw them out this year try
something original and indulgent for
Valentine's Day something that rings the
bell indulgences doubts store Montcalm
dad's store has partnered with halo
healthy tribes to create an indulgent
line of hot beverage mixes just add
water for some of the most sumptuous
mugs of hot cocoa and other flavors
mazaru matcha yogi goji hubba-hubba
pink velvet whole lotta love and I gotta
stop I'm getting getting too too hot
over here 100% natural no added sugar
loaded with MCT oil just terrific stuff
these indulgent beverages are available
in Valentine's gift packages starting as
low as 39 bucks but step up indulge her
with all six flavors save even more
enroll her in the subscription program
to get 12 additional flavors over the
year act now get ahead of the
valentine's crunch there's a special
deal for my listeners enter cough FA Co
V Fe Fe a check out save 10% act quickly
save money get Valentine's Day covered
with a gift shield appreciate that lasts
for months indulgences does store promo
Kofa fa co v fe fe 10% savings remember
indulgences dot store not calm
indulgence says dot store check it out
okay
these fact checks which are not fact
checks they're leftist opinion columns
the best one my favorite one of the
whole night came from NPR
so NPR right after this
issues this fact check they say quote
fact check President Trump praised to
the record number of women in Congress
but that's almost entirely because of
Democrats not Trump's party fact check
boom mic drop how is that a fact check
what is the fact first of all they're
talking about Trump's praising the women
in Congress praise is not something that
can be fact checked did he pretty did
praise them they're not saying he didn't
praise them you can't so okay second the
record number of women in Congress is a
fact that's a and they don't dispute
that fact and then the but the but in
their sentence is amazing because it's
totally unrelated to the first part of
it doesn't change anything about the
number of women in Congress doesn't
change anything about Donald Trump's
praise of them I don't think Donald
Trump is confused about where a lot of
those women came from I don't think he
thinks they're all Republicans it's just
the language is so amazing fact check
President Trump praised the record
number of women in Congress but that's
almost entirely because of Democrats
it's as if to say President Trump
praised the record number of women in
Congress but you should still hate him
because he's a huge jerk and I hate him
that was the fact check NPR which we're
all paying for by the way we're paying
for that back check Politico had a great
ones Politico
State of the Union fact check Trump said
quote one in three women is sexually
assaulted on the long journey north
that's partly true here's the full story
okay do you know why this so President
Trump said one in three women are raped
or sexually assaulted on the journey
across that border now the reason that
they say it's only partially true is
because the real number according to a
Doctors Without Borders study shows that
it's only 31%
ohoho they got him now president troll
oh that liar President Trump said that
liar said that 33 percent of women are
raped
sexually assaulted on the journey north
really it's only 31 boom fact-check
fact-check donald fake news alternative
facts not by the way what's funny about
this is their setting there's one
Doctors Without Borders study there are
other studies that show that the number
is much much higher between 60 and 80
percent of women are raped and sexually
assaulted that's according to an amnesty
International that's according to a
fusion survey both of which were
reported in The Huffington Post a
left-wing outlet so actually president
from probably could have used those
numbers it would have been just fine but
how disingenuous have dishonest he said
it was one in three liar it was only it
was 31% ha they're just trying to nip it
anything that he says to and even if he
doesn't lie even if he doesn't say
something that's even slightly untrue
they'll just pretend that it's untrue if
I say one in three first of all just to
just to use the phrase one in three is
to say I'm not using a precise
percentage right now if I you know if I
if let's say the number were thirty five
percent he also probably would have said
one in three it's just easier to say it
sounds better it's better rhetoric if if
that number had said thirty five percent
I bet the president would have said one
in three women are raped or sexually
assaulted crossing that border but of
course then in that case Politico would
not have that checked it because it
would have been even more in the favor
of president Trump's argument CBS I
think possibly has the most egregious of
the facts checks here is there's they
say President Trump claimed nearly five
million people have been lifted off of
food stamps but then what CBS points out
is that for last as of last September
the number of people off of food stamps
since the beginning of Trump's
presidency was only four point 1 million
now of course that was five months ago
and the number keeps increasing but they
say oh they actually this is the best
worth because they include this in their
fact check quote data for the fourth
quarter of 2018 has not yet been
published and that number had already
been trending downward before mr. Trump
took office so
okay let's so they're saying the number
is trending downward so the number of
people off of food stamps is trending
upward you're saying five months ago is
4.1 million so now who knows what that
number is it's probably significantly
higher you might say it's nearly five
million and then the kicker they this is
they're doing the same fact check thing
that NPR did they're saying and that
number had already been trending
downward before mr. Trump oh yeah he
didn't say that it wasn't when did
President Trump ever say that the number
wasn't trending downward her that it was
training upward when I never heard him
say there just yeah okay well president
Trump's right and a lot of millions and
millions of people are off of food
stamps but I hate him and he's a big
meanie and I hate him so here is the
wildest one this was in the see CBS did
a whole long list of these this is the
wildest part of the fact check Donald
Trump during the State of the Union
talked about that awful New York
abortion law read infanticide law there
was law that allows you to kill a baby
as it is being born one second before
birth you couldn't kill it not as bad as
Virginia where apparently you can kill
the baby six hours after it's been born
at least but he taught me mentions this
and the CBS fact-check tells you
everything you need to know lawmakers in
New York cheered with delight upon the
passage of legislation that would allow
a baby to be ripped from the mother's
womb moments from birth these are living
feeling beautiful babies who will never
get the chance to share their love and
their dreams with the world by the way
if you're watching that clip could Chuck
Schumer possibly look more maniacal if
he tried I think when people when people
read the Bible and they're they're
creating images in their mind for what
Moloch looks like it that Moloch almost
looks like Chuck Schumer like weak it's
very hard to visualize it's hard to
create in our minds eye something as
sinister looking as Chuck Schumer there
but look he's just there crouching hi
yes hi he's got his fingers on his leg
he's like Oh golly no he's just waiting
to eat his children hi ma'am
I'm really really creepy someone should
give him a little media training it's
amazing for a man who's lived on
television for the last 40 years he
really doesn't know how to look right on
his between this and the American Gothic
meme that he helped to create a few
months ago he really not looking great
but what did the fact-check say here's
the fact check now with all of the other
fact checks this is fact check true or
false or it says partially true
partially whatever this one it doesn't
say true and it doesn't say false it
says this facts New York's Reproductive
Health Act guarantees a woman's right to
abortion through 24 weeks of pregnancy
after that an abortion is only allowed
if a doctor decides the fetus is not
viable or to protect the patient's life
or health now of course what this really
means and they made it very clear in the
New York law is that if a patient's
mental health will be affected by having
the baby you can kill it at any point
but but that's a total cop/bad your men
I could I say yeah I'll be really sad if
I have a kid kill it then you can just
kill it immediately or the doctor says
it's non-viable what that means is if
the baby has some deformity if it's not
born like the perfect little designer
baby that it's perverted parents want or
that the perverted doctor want then they
can kill it at any given moment the way
we know this is true is that the New
York abortion law changed the New York
penal code such that before if you
killed a woman who was 24 weeks pregnant
or later you would be charged with
double homicide because you killed the
woman and you killed the baby now they
took that out of the New York penal law
if you kill a pregnant woman who is
giving birth you're only charged with
killing one person that's how it so we
know that they're trying their best to
twist it they know they can't quite so
they don't even say true or false they
just issue an endorsement of the New
York law they just say well here's the
best argument we can give for the New
York law totally transparent
there are even subtler claims and we
have to get to Stacey Abrams this
response but first let's make a little
money honey with ring rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about they're smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world you know we need to make
sure that we have border security at our
homes we need to make sure because walls
work and there are other highly
technologically advanced ways of
securing your home we should use all of
them ring is the best most
technologically advanced way to do it if
there's a package delivery there's a
surprise visitor you will get an alert
you'll be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone thanks to the
HD video and two-way audio features on
ring devices you could be in your
bedroom you could be on a beach in Boca
you could be at work it doesn't matter I
love ring ring makes me feel safer I
love having it myself I like it so much
actually that I've given it to friends
of mine when a friend of mine buys a new
home I give them ring 1 because it's
super cool and hip and like all the cool
young guys have them but it also really
really works and so if I can give them a
relatively inexpensive gift to help
protect them gives me a little peace of
mind it gives them peace of mind as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home just go to ring comm slash Knolls
kano wles ring.com slash knowles so
there are even subtler claims that they
make in these fact checks here is one
the claim the president from made this
is from president from state of the
union says unemployment has reached the
lowest rate in half a century
ok true they're saying fact check this
is inaccurate now but it was true at one
point the unemployment rate dropped to
three point seven percent in september
the lowest rate since december 1969 but
apparently since then it has ticked up a
couple tenths of a percentage point and
so they're saying yeah this isn't true
now but that's that fact check actually
is false that is a lie president Trump
said quote unemployment has reached the
lowest rate in half a century
that remains true today now obviously
the unemployment rate is going to
fluctuate it's gonna tick up a little
bit it's going to take down a little
bits not gonna stay exactly the same an
old
what he is saying is that the
unemployment rate has reached the lowest
point in half of the century during my
tenure not just during my tenure in the
last year which is what I am reporting
to you Congress that's what I am
reporting to you the American people
within the last year in this update
unemployment has reached the lowest rate
in half a century that is 100% true it's
not inaccurate now it's not partially
true it's not whatever the Democrats
that the mainstream media want to
pretend that it is just to take away the
achievements of this presidency it is
just true
the fact checkers are not true they're
liars either they're extraordinarily
stupid either they don't understand how
language works at all
you know journalists you know people who
likely major in English or literature or
journalism either they have no idea how
the English language works or they're
liars which one do you think it's
obviously Liars I also really we have to
get to the Democrat response this I was
so excited Stacey Abrams was giving the
response who is Stacey Abrams you asked
yeah I don't really know either Stacey
Abrams was the not even the majority
leader of the Georgia House of
Representatives she was the Minority
Leader of the Georgia House of
Representatives and that's it
that's who she now why on earth would
the Democrats choose her the National
Democrat Party going up against Donald
trum the president United States why
would they choose her to be the response
to the State of the Union one because
it's a thankless job that always fails
so a lot of bigger names don't want it
to she's currently doing nothing she
lost that race for Georgia governor and
she refused to concede it but now she's
got a lot of free time okay the other
reason is because the Democrats are
doubling down on identity politics
she made the stacey abrams made this a
huge point of her campaign stacey abrams
made her whole campaign about racism
disenfranchisement they are attacking
maybe as I'm a black woman that's what
her whole cynical ridiculous campaign
was about and she lost thankfully she
lost she finally conceded they stopped
the Democrats started to get carpal
tunnel writing all those fraudulent
ballots out so they finally gave up they
didn't want to hurt their wrists anymore
and the democrats choose her to give
this response because they're just as
bigoted as Stacey Abrams is they're just
as cynical as Stacey Abrams this doesn't
matter what you've accomplished
this woman has accomplished basically
nothing in her entire life and yet they
choose her over far more qualified
Democrats because of the color of her
skin and because of her sex that's what
it said because she can run the
intersectional identity politics
campaign I'm actually going to be
speaking on this topic tonight at UCLA
despite my losing my voice despite the
sickness the difficulties I am gonna
persevere because we're gonna do this
speech tonight on the bigotry of the
left specifically how the way to reduce
bigotry is to increase prejudice a topic
that seems you know we don't talk about
it a lot people don't know what bigotry
means people don't know what prejudice
means but we certainly can see the
rampant bigotry of the left and the
Democrat Party we're gonna see it here
in a second with Stacey Abrams is
response if you're writing UCLA check it
out tonight I think we're gonna stream
it to at the Daily wire so if you don't
if you don't want to come in and have me
get you sick then you can come check it
out on the Internet
we've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go to daily wire.com it's ten
bucks a month 100 dollars for an annual
membership you get me you at the end
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show you had as questions in the mailbag
you know get those in by the way the
mailbag is gonna be coming right up you
get to ask questions backstage you get
another Kingdom you get everything and
you get this I got to tell you what I'm
feeling a little under the weather as I
as I currently am i some people drink a
hot toddy
some people take off medicine some
people I didn't know you know what I do
I just open up my left just tears - oh
look at that steam you see that Oh
I'm just getting the steam from the
leftist tears and I feel as though I
could sing an opera now I feel it's
really clear it's just it makes me feel
so much healthier go over to Daly
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
all those leftist tears have fogged up
my glasses I don't mind I actually think
I can see more clearly through the
leftist tears than I could before they
had fogged up my glasses we've got to
get to this State of the Union response
it was pretty ridiculous Stacey Abrams
starts out I actually would I will make
this point relative to all the other
State of the Union responses this was
pretty good she actually did a
relatively good job I'm damning with
faint praise because they're all just
horrific but generally speaking I think
they learned their lesson from last year
when that guy Kennedy the young
red-haired Kennedy when he did it was
just it was like in a junkyard basically
had a broken-down car behind it was
really pathetic so you know obviously
Marco had Watergate where he reached for
his water and that people made fun of
him for that Bobby Jindal wasn't
grabbing they just don't go very well
they've learned some lessons which we
can identify in a second but the content
of the speech was absurd I mean it was
demand well we'll do an actual fact
check here because a lot of it was
demonstrably false and self
contradictory and you just got the
impression that Stacey Abrams is not
ready for primetime she started out for
her first two sentences strong she
started with this heartwarming story
about how her father was walking alone
in the rain and he saw a homeless man
and he gave him his jacket in the rain
and what a heartwarming story she tells
when we asked why he'd given away his
only jacket my dad turned to us and said
I knew when I left that man he'd still
be alone but I could give him my coat
because I knew you were coming for me
our power and strength as Americans
lives in our hard work and our belief in
more my family understood firsthand that
while success is not guaranteed we live
in a nation where opportunity is
possible but we do not succeed alone in
these United States when times are tough
we can persevere because our friends and
neighbors will come for us our first
responders will come for us
so what she's
blah blah happy happy platitude
platitude now whether you believe this
story about her father and I don't care
as politicians to tell these ridiculous
stories all the time my mother washed
more floors for less money then your
mother did I met Johnny in the middle of
Iowa and Johnny he just lost his job
and his whole family they all left him
and he got really sick but Johnny had $3
left in his bank account he gave it to
me for my campaign because he believes
in us so even they tell these stupid
spoke at whatever the trouble with this
story is that she contradicts herself
because she's not ready for primetime
so you hear she says ah you know my
father knew that when I left that man he
would still be alone but but when I
walked on you would come and get me but
then she goes on to say in America we're
never alone no-one's ever alone so which
isn't is the guy alone or is he not
alone this seems like a minor point it
actually matters to the larger argument
that she's making because she's
inadvertently contradicting a run point
in America here's their three options in
America are we alone and therefore we
need a bigger government to come in
because of how alone we are we need big
daddy government to come and give us the
jacket or in America are we not alone
because we have friends and family and
private charity and civic organizations
to come and help us out or in America
are we not alone because we already have
the big government Stacey Abrams is a
big government gal she wants big
government all day long though the white
knight of the government to come in and
just take money from people and give it
to favored groups and other people
that's what she wants so I don't think
she's making the argument that because
in America we have private charity and
friends and family and a rich civic
culture therefore we don't need big
government I think that choice is out so
now we have two options are we alone and
therefore we need bigger government or
are we not alone because we already have
big government
well she ends her whole talk by saying
we're not alone in America so it seems
that what she's actually concluding
is that we are not alone because we have
an adequately large government okay good
it's big enough okay go away fine bye
bye see you we're not there's no problem
we're not alone the reason that we're
not alone as we already have the big
government so we don't need a bigger
government or she's saying we are alone
and I think the point she really wants
to make is that we are alone
everything's terrible America is a
terrible awful place and therefore we
need all of her stupid big government
programs she wants to make that point
but she's not allowed to make that point
because that would be negative that
would be negative it doesn't look good
for a reaction to the State of the Union
doesn't look good for her cause she's a
a nobody who just lost her race and she
hasn't done really done anything else in
her life so that doesn't look she just
sounds like she's whining and
complaining from the sidelines but the
other reason that doesn't work is
because the economy is doing really
really well I mean America is doing very
well right now
president frumps approval rating is
doing quite well 3/4 of Americans
approved of his State of the Union
speech last night it was a very popular
speech so she can't everywhere she tries
to turn to make her argument she gets
cut off so instead she makes half of two
arguments but it's just not convincing
she just isn't ready for prime time I
guess that's the issue so then she goes
on to talk about you know the only
problem there aren't really any problems
happening right now relatively speaking
in the country so the only problems that
she can find are these contrived
problems which is the government
shutdown the government shutdown that
nobody really felt affected by there you
know a couple weeks into the shutdown
they took a poll they said how many
people feel they've really been impacted
by the shutdown they're six percent of
respondents said they had they said how
many people know that there's a
government shutdown twenty one percent
of respondents didn't even know the
government was shut down so it's the
closest thing to a real negative issue
she could find
and so she hammers it just a few weeks
ago I joined volunteers to distribute
meals to furloughed federal workers they
waited in line for a box of food and the
sliver of hope since they hadn't
received paychecks in weeks making
livelihoods of our federal workers upon
for political games is a disgrace the
shutdown was a stunt
engineered by the President of the
United States one that defied every
tenet of fairness and abandon not just
our people but our values the government
shutdown with furloughed workers
abandoned not just our people but our
value you would think from what this
woman is saying that this shutdown that
just happened was the first time ever
that the federal government shut down
maybe she thinks that I don't know what
she thinks I don't I don't think she
thinks a whole lot in reality we have
had in our history 10 government
shutdowns with furloughed workers we've
had them under both parties we've had
them under presidents of both parties
Clinton trumped whatever we've had them
all around the reason that that you can
go a long stretch without a government
shutdown is because one party basically
dominates or one ideology dominates you
know certainly before the conservative
movement started in the 1950s and 60s
you basically had the liberal consensus
you had everybody basically agreed the
same thing there was a huge I mean there
were radicals at both sides but you
basically everyone agreed on this kind
of squishy leftism
and that changed when conservatives
started to assert themselves in the
culture and in politics but a lot of
people have shut down the government
that doesn't abandon our values if
that's the case we've been abandoning
our values for decades and decades and
decades then she makes a real rhetorical
misstep our most urgent work is to
realize Americans dreams of today and
tomorrow to carve a path to independence
and prosperity that can last a lifetime
children deserve an excellent education
from cradle to career bad week to talk
about cradles Stacey bet if you're a
Democrat this is not a great week to
talk about cradles because the governor
of Virginia your party just said that we
should be able to kill babies and
cradles you know after talking to the
doctor and the mother then you should be
able to kill them in New York you know
that baby is already half way out you've
got the cradle alright and you're
allowed to kill it now in New York and
the government's cheered with delight to
quote the Democrats cheered with delight
to quote President Trump not a great
week to do that I'm it
almost a cheap shot but it's just to
show you she isn't it's just a little
weak but she goes on to make the point
that she was trying to make which
unfortunately contradicts the entire
argument of her own party we owe them
safe schools and the highest standards
regardless of zip code yet this White
House responds timidly while first
graders practice active shooter drills
and the price of higher education grows
ever steeper so what she is talking
about now is basically a cynical Lodge
she's talking about school choice and
now we need school choice we need to
stop it stop children from being
prisoner to their zip codes and allow
them to go to better schools if they can
get into those schools the Democrat
Party is explicitly fighting all
Republican efforts for school choice to
allow kids to go to better schools in
New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio leftist
Democrat is doing his best to get rid of
charter schools he is doing his best to
lock those kids largely racial minority
kids largely pour into their terrible
zip codes so that they can never get an
education that's what it is this is a
cynical lie they are and they're the
reason they're doing it is because
they're held hostage to the teacher
union who pays them a lot of money but
for her to go out there and say it it's
so bizarre I can't think of an analogy
she is saying what we need to do is the
policy that we've been fighting
Republicans on for years the policy that
Republicans want to do that we won't let
them do ridiculous then she just starts
describing things that she goes from
false advertising over her own party's
positions to just describing things that
are not true the Republican tax bill
rigged the system against working people
rather than bringing back jobs plants
are closing layoffs are looming and
wages struggle to keep pace with the
actual cost of living we owe more to the
millions of everyday folks who keep our
economy running what are you talking
about the economy has been booming for
over two years we have record low
unemployment we have record low black
unemployment we have record low Hispanic
unemployment the economy basically could
not be doing better Michelle
okay well that line didn't work let's
talk about the caged children we know
bipartisanship could craft a 21st
century immigration plan but this
administration chooses to cage children
and tear families apart
caged children there was a photo that
went viral of caged children people
blamed Donald Trump for it the photo was
from the Obama administration Donald
Trump isn't choosing to cage children
why are we caging children which really
they mean separating illegal alien kids
from the adults that are with them who
knows if it's their parents often it's
coyotes and human traffickers well the
reason that we're doing that is because
of an agreement the Flores Agreement
from 1997 from the Clinton
administration which said that we can
throw these little kids in jail the
parents have to go to criminal holding
but the kids don't have to go to jail so
we're going to separate them and put the
kids in a nicer place so we who do we
have to thank for that Bill Clinton and
Barack Obama and then that she makes her
selfish argument she wants to make this
selfish argument on that voter
suppression because she insists that the
election was stolen from her in Georgia
who is stolen because the Democrats got
carpal tunnel writing all those
fraudulent ballots so they couldn't
ultimately give her the office she talks
about voter suppression unfortunately
again
she makes the opposite point let's be
clear voter suppression is real from
making it harder to register and stay on
the rolls to moving and closing polling
places to rejecting lawful ballots we
can no longer ignore these threats to
democracy well I acknowledge the results
of the 2018 election here in Georgia I
did not and we cannot accept efforts to
undermine our right to vote oh I agree
Stacy I agree voter fraud is real that's
what you said right voter fraud voter
fraud is real
we know this there was a big survey that
just came out in Texas a big study
showed a rampant voter fraud
non-citizens registered to vote to the
tune of what fifty nine thousand I think
had voted cases of voter fraud illegal
votes cancel out legitimate votes if you
allow someone to
vote illegally then it is exactly the
same as taking away someone's right to
vote
there is no difference their vote will
not count best way to secure the vote
Stacy I'm with you we ought to secure
the vote with voter ID that's the best
way to do it because then those tens and
tens of thousands of people won't be
voting in Texas who shouldn't be voting
and then tens and tens of thousands of
votes won't be canceled out tens and
tens of thousands of people won't have
their right to vote
effectively cancelled I will leave on a
sort of nice note to Stacey Abrams this
was relatively better than most of the
responses the reason is the framing of
it
the reason these don't work as president
Trump has the biggest audience and he's
got the world but then he's in the
capital this grand auditorium
he's got the vice-president the speaker
behind him he's got all of these you
know 500 congressmen and Senators in
front of him and so it's just so grand
and then they film the reaction in a
little tiny broom closet they basically
film it in my studio upstairs what
Stacey Abrams did is she put all it's
kind of weird it's all of these people
behind her and they were all in a blurry
you couldn't you know you couldn't make
out faces really all different colors
and men and women and they were and they
were enough in the back that I didn't
even I assumed it was probably a green
screen or something and but you still
got the feeling that she's surrounded by
people this is just a basic lesson for
political rallies you want to be
surrounded by people so it looks like
you've got a lot of support I thought
that was a really smart revision to the
response to the State of the Union but
it fell flat
Trump won the night and and for now we
can say proudly happily hopefully
America will never be a socialist
country
check us out tonight at UCLA and if
you're not there then I'll see you
tomorrow on the show get your mailbag
questions in in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Danny D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa Elvira production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19